it took hundreds of thousands of years
for the world's population to hit 1
billion then over 200 years it grew
Sevenfold now there's eight billion
people living on planet Earth that means
that more than a billion were born just
over the last decade
the United Nations credits longer
lifespans high fertility rates in
certain countries and increasing
urbanization for the exponential growth
despite this Milestone fertility rates
are at an all-time low more than 60
countries around the world are expected
to shrink demographically
foreign
births have been steadily declining in
the United States Europe and Japan even
China with its 1.4 billion population is
struggling with the legacy of its one
child policy
but even with declining fertility rates
the population here in Nigeria could
exceed 400 million in just 13 years it
has one of the fastest growth rates
globally along with India Pakistan and
Tanzania just to name a few
if current trends continue sub-Saharan
Africa will contribute more than half of
the global population increase through
to 2050. this is coming at a high price
the challenges facing Humanity are acute
and millions of people are living in
poverty and hunger with limited access
to health care and as women continue to
be denied the fundamental rights to
choose whether or not they want to Bear
children growth will go unchecked and
the number of people living in
uninhabitable conditions will continue
to soar